The millions of goods that are being
educated.
The millions of children that are
getting vaccines,
the thousands of civil society
organizations that have been
strengthened in the fight for human
rights and in the fight against
corruption should made us proud about
eight because this is what aid is being
used for.
These are the red hots that aid is
producing.
At the same time,
the development financing landscape is
changing dramatically.
Countries are racing more domestic
resources through taxation.
Private sector is investing more and new
donors are playing an increasing role.
So in this context,
does it have a future?
My answer is yes.
Okay.
The other question is,
is that future going to be the same as
in the past?
My answer is equally clear.
No.
In order to remain relevant in this
changing landscape,
eight has got to become smarter.
What does that mean in practice?
To me it means at least the things it
means.
First of all,
that is going to be used where it's most
needed in countries,
areas to people that have less access to
other sources of funding.
Secondly,
it's got to be used to strengthen
countries own capacities.
To solve their problems.
So the lessons of the Paris Declaration
of the and agenda for action and of the
somme used country systems,
they are still relevant.
But thirdly,
it's got to be used smarter to catalyze
other sources of funding,
to help mobilize private funding,
to help increase taxation,
to help use remittances better,
uh,
for development.
And I think if we use eight smarter than
it will be possible to continue to
convince taxpayers in countries that are
struggling at present that aid is
relevant also in the future.